so after the conclusion of dialogue we
have
with us uh mr hanifatmir the foreign
minister acting foreign minister
afghanistan thank you very much for
taking the time
the two obstacles the major obstacles
about
the jurisprudence as well as the
inclusion
of the loya jirga or the continuation of
the doha deal remain
sticking points have you made any
progress how hopeful
are you because i spoke to some
diplomats and they say
if you look at the glass half full at
least nobody has walked out of the table
yet
yes we we are indeed hopeful that we
will be able to resolve them that's why
we have engaged
in a new chapter of diplomacy
with our regional and international
partners to create
conditions in which these obstacles can
be resolved
nobody expected that these negotiations
would be easy
everybody predicted obstacles or variety
now we've made some good progress on
most of
the issues related to the rules of
procedure but there are these two
pending issues and hopefully
we will find ways to resolve them by the
way the government of afghanistan
through its team negotiating team
have actually presented a number of
counter proposals
to find a common ground
for agreement so we've seen at least
four of these proposals that have been
presented by the negotiation team to the
taliban now the ball
according to the team is in the
taliban's court and they have to come up
with something which both sides can
agree on
but the taliban continue to say that
they don't even recognize
the afghan government as a legitimate
government and they see it
as a party to the conflict so how
hopeful are you that you are going to
make progress
and what is at stake here
well for
any boring party to use that kind of
language is not something new
it should be expected we don't recognize
we don't want to talk to
them these are the things we've heard
but the reality now
is that we have face face-to-face direct
negotiation between the two sides and
this is
a progress that we welcome
now we do have obstacles and this
is exactly the purpose of the
negotiation
to remove these obstacles and finally
now that it's been
nearly three weeks since this uh
dialogue began
talks seemed to have stalled and the
only
sticking point seems to be the two
sticking points that you mentioned
uh it's not moving forward and there is
no reduction in violence hundreds of
people have been killed in afghanistan
what makes you sure that this time
around with your help of your partners
you'd be able to tell the taliban to
reduce violence we are quite hopeful
those who would insist on
violence would be extremely
marginalized and they will not have
uh any legitimacy in any of their causes
to pursue
thank you so much thank you very much mr
honey pepper uh there you have that was
the foreign minister
acting foreign minister of afghanistan
after meeting qatari as well as american
officials telling us
that he is still hopeful that dialogue
is the way forward
and both sides are going to come to some
sort of an agreement to reduce violence
you